oh I got through this story because it's
just sweet sweet sweet it happened a
little while ago but we can't go without
mentioning it and the only reason I want
to do is because it was said to me this
week I didn't know about it but here's
the clip of the Ewok made the Ewok
picture up there James you could show us
this news story hit the news paper Ewok
on indecency charge it reads Nicholas
Reed who played an Ewok in Return of the
Jedi was arrested for showing his penis
to a 17 year old on a train this week it
gets funnier
Nicholas Reed was playing one of the
Seven Dwarfs in a snow-white pantomime
which is like a play they do in England
right he had a bottle of gin according
to friends he got on the train on the
way home from the show Brad's dissidence
holding view at all I'm sorry I forgot
we have a I have a [ __ ] friend in the
crowd tonight I don't want to be too
rude he got on the on the train in his
dwarf costume took off his dwarf hat
what it is laughs pulled out his [ __ ]
and then a 17 year old sitting across
from over the train he started flashing
his [ __ ] by lifting up the dwarf hat
periodically and giving her the eyes
look down in here look down here showing
off his dwarf [ __ ] that's your move guy
totally ripped you off
I believe that move is called the hi-ho
thank you and good night
Nicolas who also played one of the
Gringotts goblins in the Harry Potter
and the Philosopher's Stone played an
Ewok warrior in Return of the Jedi oh
this guy he is 40 all right so they made
I'm 40 okay would you like to show us
your [ __ ] yes it just means they made
Return of the Jedi like 1982 so he was
what 12 when he was in Return of the
Jedi maybe they had burn ro the part
enough
he places had on his crotch said the
young lady who was the victim of the
crime I didn't know whether to believe
it or not she said he tilted the hat
towards me lifted it so I could see the
lewd behavior continued for 30 to 40
minutes she added he tried to catch my
attention tilting up his hat looking at
his crotch and then looking at me a few
times she told the cops who showed up
and when they took him into court they
asked him why didn't you just hang your
hat up on the coat rack sir
he answered I [ __ ] you not in court
because I couldn't reach he has been
found guilty has not been charged yet
but apparently there was another
previous incident in 2004 he was also
performing in a snow white play in
England where he climbed into bed with
the stage manager and his girlfriend had
assaulted the woman before she knew that
he was there
he is one pervy little Ewok a dude [ __ ]
it just sitting on the train just
putting a hat over there back there that
that's unbelievable
maybe he was just trying to hide as much
of cold eye filing that was good
straight from Dublin
[Music]